[Musique]
le xénon genre est une identité de genre
non binaire c'est aussi un terme
parapluie qui permet de décrire son
genre via des métaphores et des
analogies ensuite il y a la
caractérisation par la perception
synesthésique la synesthésie c'est quand
une sensation s'accompagne d'une
sensation complémentaire en simultanée
dans un autre endroit du corps moi par
exemple j'associe les mots au goût
perception synesthésique donc le genre
est décrit avec des éléments comme le
temps la texture la taille ou d'autres
caractéristiques sensorielles pour
exemple je fréquente une personne
xénophore flag de couleur
[Musique]
ah oui il faut pas confondre xéno genre
et oderkin les overkills sont des gens
qui pensent que leur âme et celle d'un
animal dans un corps humain les
personnes xénophores savent qu'elles
sont humains ou humaines d'où le côté
métaphorique encore une fois